well hundreds of families got an early  Christmas today as part of a mission to  help the underserved and unite  communities for the second year in a row  local nonprofit rescued the children  organized the event at the new light  Missionary Baptist Church near MLK and  Laurie Avenue well families there were  able to enjoy music and food the kids  got some toys and even got to hang out  with Santa Claus  anything that I can do to help the youth  in my community I definitely want to  always make sure I give back  um to me it's it's heartwarming it gives  me a sense of humility as well because  not everyone is blessed as we are a lot  of smiles today all right the event was  made possible thanks to a partnership  between the light Baptist Church Panda  Express and Toys for Tots among others  now if you would like to donate or learn  more about the group you can visit the  website uh rescuethechildrenlv.org